former Nickelodeon star Drake Bell found
alive hours after he was reported
missing oh hey hey why don't you climb
in and fling yourself out of my room
this is my room it was my room first on
Thursday the Daytona Beach Police
Department declared the actor missing
and endangered in a post on their
official Facebook page revealing he was
last seen driving a 2022 gray BMW on
Wednesday around 9pm somewhere near the
area of Mainland High School be scary
because it could be dangerous and when
some people online questioned if the
whole thing was a hoax the police
replied online that it was very much
real but in an update the dbpd confirmed
that law enforcement officials are in
contact with Drake and he is safe ET has
reached out to Drake's rep for comment
this is a really rough business it's a
and it means it's not even in this
industry just life in general you know I
mean everybody goes through some form of
depression or or sadness in their life
Drake's had a lot of trouble since his
time on Drake and Josh in 2021 he was
sentenced to two years probation and 200
hours of community service in connection
to his high-profile child endangerment
case in which he pled guilty according
to multiple outlets in addition to
probation and community service hours
the judge ruled at the time that Drake
was prohibited from contacting the
victim who met Drake online and attended
one of his concerts in Cleveland in 2017
when she was 15 years old he's faced
other accusations over the years
including a 2015 DUI arrest he also
filed for bankruptcy in 2014 but in 2021
some happy news Drake revealed he
secretly married his girlfriend Janet
Von Schmeling and welcomed a son